that's what I would do I wouldn't let
anything stop me from having a baby um
especially if I can pay as long as I'm
paying cash for it absolutely Ken I
agree and kenis let me say that my wife
Stacy and I went through seven years of
infertility so I just want to kind of
speak to your heart here and say that um
you're going to be a mama I believe that
I don't know how and I do not know when
uh but I understand what you guys are
going through certainly from a male
perspective I do not understand the
female perspective but walked through
that with Stacy and I know this is a
tough time and I agree wholeheartedly
with Jade um this is your process I
don't want you to go into debt do
everything possible to not go one penny
into debt but yes I would absolutely
pursue this do you know what it's going
to cost have you been able to research
that a little bit um yeah so it looks
like um each round of IUI is going to be
about $1,000 okay um and then if we end
up being you know if we don't find
success and we go through IVF route um
my out- of pocket will be like 15,000
okay and you feel confident that you
guys can cash flow that I mean I know we
can the Thousand doll um the 15 is what
really scares me um you know and I'm
planning want to plan for the worst case
scenario well so so let me let me
interrupt for just a second because true
I I don't want you to misunderstand what
Jade and I are saying yes we want you to
do this but but when you're going I'm
scared then then then I would compile
the 15 before I start this I would not I
would not go down this route where your
heart's going to go we're going to the
next level and then we get there and we
have nothing that is so detrimental and
so I would be sitting down at the at the
kitchen table tonight Jade yes and I'd
be going what must we do yes to scrap
scrape everything but steal $155,000 I'm
looking for what I can sell I'm looking
for what what we can I mean I'm I'm sure
you've got a good amount of margin
already because you've been doing the
debt snowball what's your margin every
month um we have about 3,000 every month
okay so if we're really months when
we're really strong yeah uh in five
months no if you if you were to side
hustle can you get this in six months
five months if you were to add a little
to that yeah probably I've been working
on a side hustle that I started a couple
months ago but it's slow going no no so
this is so let me tell you what I mean
by side hustle and what Jade means we
don't mean start your own little
business this is like this is a side job
parttime you are going and you are
stocking groceries at the grocery store
for $16 an hour I want $20 an hour Ken
well yeah I'm just giving an example go
go go get you what you can get uh I
don't want to hang the grocery job on
you I'm saying that with the margin that
Jade found for you guys and I heard you
say well 3,000 a month if we're really
really disciplined I don't know what
what else is going to make you more
disciplined than trying to get a baby M
and so this is serious business you
cannot allow I think is going to put a
dent in it is student lanss starting
next month coming back but hey but
that's reality and let's talk about
let's talk about that we're hey we're
going to talk about keep listening
because we're going to talk about
student loans and I'm going to talk
about some things that I think are going
to help you it's not for this call right
now but keep listening and I would you
know if you guys are to a barebones bud
budget now you got $3,000 of margin
great can you and your I think each of
you and your husband can find another
$1,000 a month I think you can I know
you can and it it is going to require a
lot of work but again if you can do that
it's five or six months of work it's
half a year and then you can go into
these treatments feeling confident that
okay now I hope the the Thousand thing
works for you and you don't even have to
go that next route but if you do you'll
have the piece of knowing hey we've got
the cash here we won't be making an
emotional decision and we're fully
prepared for it yep you cannot Candace
you cannot allow the thought to enter
your mind that will just borrow it you
don't want that you can do this by the
way you and your husband have been very
patient there's there's very few things
harder than waiting on a baby yeah and
and that tells me you guys can wait long
enough and it shouldn't be very long to
come up with 15 cash put it aside and
that's if we need to get it we're hoping
that the other treatments
work um and let me also say this Candace
I want the best I'm hoping the best but
there's no guarantee that any of this
stuff works absolutely and and and so
your mindset has to be I have to make
good decisions in the now that don't
hurt me in the next because the last
thing you want is a bunch of debt on
something that didn't work yikes you
know what I mean I don't want to be
grieving J and then paying on something
I'm grieving yeah that's tough well I
for one and believing that this is going
to this I know I know you are but I just
wanted I wanted to end it on that I know
that upbeat but I feel like we have to
say that though because because debt
sucks enough but then when it's tied to
something that hurts it turns a blessing
that was a blessing to a burden yeah and
we don't we don't want that yeah let's
go to Beth now in Los Angeles Beth how
can Jade and I
help hi okay so I have a question um we
bought it started we're on baby step 2 I
am selling everything I've got two
Facebook Marketplace meetups today
because I'm trying to get my debt paid
off is coming so I'm trying um I have a
question I filled out my public loan
service loan forgiveness I have 90 uh
$89,000 in student loan debt one of them
is 48,000 one of and then I have two
20,500 the 48,000 one I have 41 payments
left in order for me to qualify for for
Public service loan forgiveness so four
years my question for four yeah so four
years basically three years and six
months um my question is is when I do
the every dollar it says like track your
like that snowball correct so I have a
car loan for 5,000 and then I have two
student loans at
20,500 and then I have this one at
48,000 okay that would be the last one
I'll pay off if I make the minimum
payment um just kind of per Dave
Ramsey's every dollar now I'm at 6 years
from my payoff date my question is is
should I still just like work on the
minimum monthly payments for my 48,000
and since of public loan forgiveness
should forgive it in almost four years
what I would do um I would not focus on
the loan forgiveness because I think you
can do this faster than what you think
so we've got let's see 40 80,000 plus
the car how much are you earning every
month um so we're at 10,000 every month
um when I break everything down I can
make on loan payments about 1500 is like
I can throw towards my monthly payments
what are you paying a month what are you
paying a month for a rent 3400 all right
your rent's too high you're paying to
you're spending way too much um we need
to find a way to get this rent down I
don't know if it's just you it sounds
like there's somebody else there um and
I think you can do this faster I would
never wait on around for forgiveness you
need to side hustle whoever's working
with you on this if it's a spouse they
need to get on board and let's get this
paid off quickly um I'm not waiting
around four years king Coleman no no and
I wouldn't guarantee that it's going to
get forgiven anyway we got to stop
waiting on this go ahead follow the baby
steps the dead snowball that's the plan
no deviation this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and lumps some
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show where we
talk with you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
Jade warshaw this hour8 8255
2258 825 5225 is the number to jump in
let's go to Grand Island uh Nebraska
where Matt is Matt how can we help hey
guys thanks for taking my call you bet
what's what's up hey just a quick
question and uh Ken I guess this is more
your wheelhouse here um I'm currently in
a working for a company that I've been
with for around five years now um and I
feel like um compared to other people in
my industry I feel like I'm um I guess
inadequately paid I was just wondering
with an eval coming up here in about a
couple of weeks I was wondering how the
best way is to ask for a uh raise yeah
okay let's go to uh what you said there
you feel like you're inadequately paid
is that feeling based on any kind of
fact uh yeah so uh in I work in the egg
industry and uh kind of related to my
job I know other people are making uh
probably 30,000 more than me um similar
similar skill similar
experience um I'd say with for them it'd
be less um work but um maybe more year
round type stuff like I'm paid a salary
obviously but um Summers and springs and
Falls are more labor intensive than like
Winters because it is the industry so
when crops aren't growing you know not
not a lot to do well okay and and I
don't want to get in the weeds here but
why I'm asking about similar skill and
experiences is if you can actually walk
in and that's what I'm trying to get you
to is walk in and go look I did some
research and based on the market and
that's again using that term as a here's
if I look at high medium and low on the
range of salary or hourly pay because
it's it's it's all the same basic deal
for you in this situation where are you
with those people that are making much
more than you so are you middle are you
low are you you know and and then is the
experience and the skill set very
similar to where you could go I based on
this it looks as though I could make
this in the marketplace I want to start
there so I want to I want to make sure
we get this do you feel like you've got
the evidence real fact-based evidence
that you could show on paper with real
sources that you are
underpaid yes so I have uh some friends
that do in the same industry to
something different and um they have
told me and I've actually kind of looked
into some other things okay saying that
they that that kind of backs up what I
when was the last time you got a raise
if you've been there five
years uh so it's every year but it's
only for the past five years I've been
there total I probably got like a 15%
raise since I started which I started
and it wasn't okay so you're getting
about the 3% raise which is pretty
standard a 3% bump every year so that's
what you're getting and so what would
this equate to if you got the if you got
if you got the bump that you want how
much of a bump would it be percentage
wise um I've run the numbers
and so I guess without getting too deep
into it we get paid based on like how
much we bring in essentially and um is
that a Commission job more you bring it
no it's more of a like a revenue based
for like re certain goals and then you
get like a certain percentage okay um if
that makes sense it does so so I guess
it's um sitting with some other people
in our company that have kind of helped
me out with this coming up or eval
coming up they said that kind of shoot
for the stars and ask for like a you
know 60 to 50% raise um just to see if
what they would do there but all right
so here's my advice okay and you can
take what you like of this and you can
leave what you don't like
um I always tell people don't come in
and just say I want a race I just think
that coming in and dropping it like that
just always creates a situation where
your leader could feel very defensive
and they're trying to how do I answer
that they want to have time to figure
that out so what I would come in and say
I would just say this over the last 5
years at these evals I'm getting the 3%
bump it's come to my attention I've done
the research I've got friends and people
that work at other organizations don't
mention anybody internally just like
this is what I've seen out there in the
marketplace and I want to get there and
so the question
is can we come to some sort of agreement
on how I can get there I'd like to get
there now um but I also know that you've
got to measure my performance I just
don't want to make demands I want to
make a request do you see the
difference yes and I want to say I've
done the research and I can I should I
mean the marketplace says I could make
this I'd like to make that here what has
to be true for that to happen and leave
it in his in he or her lap his or her
lap on that don't just go in and demand
it say what has to be true for me to get
there because I want to get there and so
they're going to a automatically know
that you've done your homework and that
you see a much better opportunity out
there and so you're going to find out
pretty quickly whether or not they want
you there and what they're willing to do
and I think that just that is going to
force the conversation without demanding
it so yes ask for it but not directly
it's an indirect ask to go I want to be
making this how realistic is that here
and if it's realistic what do I have to
do those are the two specific questions
then you know where you stand exactly I
think the way you approach this is
everything having the facts having the
information the tone you know what I'm
saying yeah all that matters and now
you've got a great spirit about you so I
don't in any way see you going in there
you know absolutely sliding a paper
across the desk
going I'd like you to respond to that
that's the old school way Slide the
number does that
help yes it helps a lot thank you yeah
but the facts listen the facts the facts
the facts when it comes to this kind of
thing and tell people this is what I'd
like mhm and and and and I'd like to
know is it possible there was a two-part
question there and then what must happen
for this to be possible then you're
going to find out really fast you get a
gray answer and they go but well I'll
get back to you and they never get back
to you there's your sign that's so good
Ken that's such good advice so many
people go into that conversation based
on the way they feel oh yes and not only
that but what they feel they're entitled
to yeah yeah and by the way you might be
right but that doesn't mean that the
boss thinks that you're right true that
so you've got to bring him along and I'm
a little bit nervous about the advice he
got uh from his co-workers CU he's
gotten a 3% bump for five straight years
and they're telling him hey shoot for
the moon okay what's that uh ask for a
50% raise well if you can't document
that that's reasonable here's what you
do your Genius co-workers told you to
shoot for the Moon you just shot
yourself in the foot yeah you did you
did so come on really 50% that's a lot
that's a big hype unless you could like
show how you have show it doubled you
know the revenue that you've created for
that company yikes you know something
like that it's like otherwise you I
think of a sports metaphor here and this
is really important because this is an
issue that always gets controversy when
I get asked and it's on social media but
if you got let's take football football
season's about ready to start okay and
let's say let's say you're a two or
three-year running back you've had a
couple of good years you didn't lead the
league you weren't an all pro you're a
good running back M and you don't like
your contract situation and you and your
agent go in there and you start
demanding I want this this and this well
guess what they're going to do if you
ask for an outrageous salary that is not
at the market value of an NFL running
back that is in your position guess what
they're going to say they're going to
say I can find a guy that does it just
like you I just drafted a kid I just
drafted a kid that may be as good as you
and I have to pay him the league minimum
and that's where you shoot yourself in
the foot by overplaying a hand like
you've got Aces and you got let's call
it 46 not even suited you like that
poker analogy I like that K good job so
a lot of people just because I feel like
I want to make more money doesn't mean
that I've got a strong case to make more
money and and feelings will get you in
trouble fast yeah and there's always
that thing is is there somebody standing
right behind you that does the job just
as good as you that would make that
would be happy with that Sal promise you
you know what they'll do they'll go to
somebody go listen I'm going to give you
a nice little bump to take their half
their workload just for about 6 months I
promise you your co-worker is going to
be like bye see you bye what's that song
is that that's it what's that is there
an insync song Friday bye bye bye is
that in Bye Bye Bye there it is see see
when you co-host with Jade warshaw you
tear her up and she sings a bar for you
and sings it well she's Jade I'm Ken
this is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show hey guys being free to make your
own medical decisions is a big deal
these days Christian healthare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget welcome back to the Ramsey show
where we talk with you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships I'm Ken Coleman Jade
warshaw joins me we're here for youle
8825 5225 is the number 8825 5225 and if
you're new to the program and and Jay
this is exciting we were in a meeting
recently where we're hearing about just
a lot of new people coming to us from
all over the place every platform radio
SiriusXM podcast YouTube it's it's
extraordinary and so we want to welcome
you but we also know we've got this
jargon we got this language like baby
steps gazelle intense baby step six baby
step two dead snowball a lot of stuff
and you're going okay I'm trying to
catch up right so we'd love to invite
you to go to our website ramsy
solutions.com and we have a wonderful
little get started assessment takes just
a couple minutes and it'll kind of get
you caught up to where you are in your
finances and and help you understand oh
I get the steps now I see where I am and
I see what I've got to do so go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on get started
and that'll catch you up pretty quickly
and we got a lot of great resources for
you let's go to the phones Tampa Florida
is where Patrick is Patrick how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
yeah you bet what's
up so um last night me and my wife sat
down to a meeting with our financial
advisor and uh it was in regards to
options for saving for college we
already have a 529 for my youngest
daughter and my my oldest daughter has a
prepaid plan that her grandfather paid
for years ago when she was born um so
last night the financial advisor uh
tried to sell us on a whole life
insurance whole like a whole life
insurance plan as an option for saving
for my youngest daughter's College red
flag obviously yeah huge red flag right
okay all right so I'm not crazy thank
you no you know what I need I need a
yellow flag like the NFL ref and I just
throw it at the camera when I hear stuff
like that let's go Ken I wish I had one
I like that tell him why that's crazy
Jade um I just it's such a bad product
financially and you have the ability to
lose so much money on the investment
side I can't imagine any investment
adviser withth their salt suggesting
that unless they're just trying to get
more commission out of you and that's
honestly what's happening in this case
100 as the kids say who is who is this
who is this guy is this somebody you
knew before is this an uncle is this you
know you can just drop him like it's hot
then so we we were very interested did
in biblically responsible investing if
I'm saying that right B and uh we went
through I'm going to drop names Inspire
insight and uh he was an he was a
financial adviser that worked with them
that uh like contacted us and you know
we were we just agreed like hey this guy
sounds good we're on baby step seven
we're doing great so let's let's just go
with this guy and you know and um you
red flag last night you know Patrick
first of all as Jade said it's bad and
and and we have very clear positions on
the whole life where she can explain to
our audience if necessary but let me
tell you something you don't even need
it based on what you laid out you guys
have already got your 529 set up and and
now it's just play play the plan you
don't need it yeah oh we were just
looking for options because the 529
through Florida Florida Prepaid doesn't
offer BR like options you know so that's
the only reason we were going like
looking and asking him so okay so let's
let let me kind of make sure I
understand this because I'm not really
sure what the 529 has anything to do
with your life insurance right I I for
me it has zero to do with
it because for for you and for anybody
listening the purpose of life insurance
is to replace your income for anybody
who's dependent on your income that's
the only reason for it and many people
get to a point with their net worth that
they don't even really need it anymore
because if they were to pass away
there's enough there to take care of
anybody who would have been dependent on
that in on that um income so on that
note um the two are not related I still
would suggest unless you've got a super
high net worth that we don't know about
I would still suggest that you go with a
term life plan um do you understand why
we're suggesting
that oh yeah totally and we have terized
plans and really maybe my ultimate
question is should I be looking for
another financial adviser yeah I would
um I don't like I don't like when people
try to take me for a ride that's my
thing like
don't he was assuming that you didn't
understand and so he tried to play you
and I don't like that and you came in
the way you should with your own set of
knowledge understanding things and you
were able to go hey this is a red flag
now for me I Pro that would be enough
for me to move on it really would um you
could bring it to him and say hey here's
why I don't want to do this and you
could lay it out and say I don't like
this cash value thing I don't like the
investment I don't like the fact that I
can get a better rate of return if I
invest that same sum of money myself I
don't like the fact that when I die
someone else gets the cash value like or
that you know the the company keeps the
cash value if you say it to him like
that and I don't like the fact that you
sold me a product that's worse for me so
you could get a better commission I
would I just like confrontation so I
might just like to have that
conversation just to see how he'd react
but if he says anything less than I am
so sorry I don't know what I was
thinking you know maybe you could try to
pick up the pieces but I'd probably just
move on yeah it's like trying to argue
with somebody in a cult a you ain't
going to win I'm serious you're not
going to win so I you know I agree with
Jade but I would move on make money off
you let's be very clear let's invest in
things that are specific to what we need
and you've already got the 529s ready to
go you've got your insurance you don't
need whole life and so and this brri
thing also freaks me out a little bit
there's nothing in the Bible about whole
life insurance so let's be very careful
I want you to hop on with Ramsey with
one of our providers cuz talk to several
smart vest reporters in your area yeah
we interview exactly and and that's the
key interview these folks I'm not just
talking to our caller anybody who's out
there these people are working for you
we we can't tiptoe around them like you
know scared to ask questions and scared
to put them on the spot you're giving
them a percentage you're paying them
they they in in essence you are their
emplo employee because you're providing
work for them and you're paying them for
their service and so interview them and
don't be afraid to be like hard pass
yeah and and listen you cannot invest in
anything that you do not understand
that's a fact you can't take their word
for it you've got to know it in this
case to Patrick credit uh he's like he
did know it whole life stinks it smells
I don't like it um and I do think you
need to be with someone that you're
aligned with you should and I can what I
commend him on is sometimes when we get
in a situation with people who are good
at math right they're they're good with
money we start questioning we just have
that impostor syndrome and assume they
know more than us but your instinct does
count for something and when you're
talking with someone and you get that
feeling of like ooh like uh I didn't
like that the spidey sense yeah the
spidey sense goes off you know you get
the the heebie jeebies oh that's a good
one you know I've had a case of the
heebie jeebies a time or two hopefully I
didn't give them to you but you know no
no never
but you know you're right you just don't
have a piece about it you don't have
peace yep you know and it's like okay
what's happening here and why is it
happening yeah that doesn't feel right
yeah and when that happens stop and do
what our guy did and either talk to your
spouse call into the show and at if you
don't get peace then move on yeah and by
the way we need to be clear when we talk
about smart investor Pros they are not
employees of this company work for us
they are independent financial advisers
that are very very good they are in
alignment with a philos opy but if you
go to Ramy solutions.com and we really
recommend this click on the smartvestor
pro button talk to a few go meet with
them it's kind of like picking the the
your your hairdresser or your dentist
that's good Ken you know what I mean
it's kind of be like I'm not going to
let anybody put their hands in my mouth
yeah they're going to be all up in your
stuff you better make sure you trust
them yeah and to your point you said
something earlier they shouldn't be
selling you on something that makes them
a nice commission they should be helping
you make money and because you make
money money they make money Bingo big
difference that's a big difference and
and that's what we're saying that's why
we don't like whole life it is not a
good bu the numbers program does not
benefit you that's right you're paying
you're paying a larger amount per month
because that money is being split over
two areas you're getting your death
benefit but there's also a portion of
your payment that's being invested over
time that's a cash benefit right but the
problem there is the money that's being
invested the rate of return on that guys
is so poor sometimes it's like 2% Ken 2%
you better invest that money yourself
the only thing I like that's 2% is a
glass of milk no no Ken I'm not with you
on that it's cuz you're a clean healthy
eater that's right but for people like
me that like to live a little bit give
me the cashew milk Kim J you ain't
having no fun drinking cashew milk I
promise you right now I'm having fun
when I dunk my Oreo into some real
milk all right we'll fight about that on
the
break she's Jade warsh I'm Ken Coleman
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the ramsy way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's Ramy
solutions.com to sign up for our weekly
newsl
[Music]
letter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions broadcasting from the
PODS moving and storage Studio this is
the Ramsey Show it's where we help you
win in your life specifically with your
money in your work and in your
relationships I'm Ken I'm joined by Jade
warshaw The Fabulous Jade warshaw joins
me in the studio today
aa825 5225 8825 5225 Jade is your money
expert she'll walk you through all
things baby steps she's got a great
personal story she understands every
angle of this game so make the phone
call I'm here to help on your work life
you can't talk about money and not at
least be thinking about work as Dave has
said Dave Ramsey has said for decades
your income is your greatest wealth
building tool and I'm here to help you
there do I need to make a transition do
I need to get promoted do I start the
side hustle that is my game and so we do
that together and we're excited to be
together let's go now to Salt Lake City
Utah where Britney is on the line
Britney how can we help hi thank you so
much for taking my call you bet what's
up Britney yeah so my husband his truck
payment is almost as much as our more
oh boy hold on let me get the peps out
how much are we talking about Britney so
it's it's right over
1400 oh boy I'm feeling faint Jade I'm
faint I went into James Brown mode wow
goodness
gracious so yes
we we have Total Money Makeover we're
currently um about to start Financial
Peace University she understands why we
don't use credit cards and all that but
when it com from his truck when comes to
the truck he says I work hard I deserve
a nice truck but I'm just trying to
figure out if there's some magic words I
can say and I got the magic words I got
the magic words you're sleeping on the
couch hey okay oh watch out no I'm sorry
that's probably not the best marital
advice but I do think Jade at this point
we've got a serious conversation he
can't be taking the baby steps seriously
and justifying a
$1,400 truck payment I mean I just want
to know when people say things like I
deserve deserve I'm like really you
deserve to be in debt I cuz I feel like
I deserve to be debt-free I deserve to
have a future I deserve to not live
paycheck to paycheck I deserve to be
able to have the margin to invest for my
future for my children like people need
to reframe when they say what they
deserve or not um so that could be a
place where you start but in all good uh
calmed down
advice Ken and I kind of went off the
the spout there um you do need to sit
down and you do need to have a
conversation and it needs to be an adult
conversation because right now I mean
I'm not saying this in an insulting way
but he's in a selfish mode and he's kind
of in a uh for right now mode and we
need to get in a more futuristic there's
more ahead of us than just right now
there's more people that are um feeling
the effects of this than him and so
being able to have that conversation is
going to be really important to you um
and I have found that when you
use language that's kind of like hey I'm
I here's what I'm afraid of I'm afraid
XYZ or here's what I'm so excited for
and if we could just get to this that
would give me so much joy like if you
can really find ways to bring um your
fears into it but also like the things
that would just cause you so much
happiness and joy in life those are big
markers and should be big markers uh for
the people who love you and care about
you they should want to hear about those
things and when you share those things
it should cause them to make a reaction
does that make sense yeah no that
makesense what's the what's your
take-home pay um together almost 200
okay good good 200,000 take-home yes way
to go okay so you look even at that kind
of income I mean this is a huge chunk of
your monthly budget $1,400 m
massive and the truck 1600 oh my gosh
and and and how long ago did he get the
truck um about six months ago and and
what did he pay for it um I think it was
like 85 or 90 oh my gosh I'm light
headed again so 80 to 90,000 and and you
know what would be very interesting in
this conversation Jade tell me if I'm
wrong here but as I'm sharing those
feelings of what that does to you and
how it makes you feel you've got to
point out
how that it' be fun to get a an
amortization schedule like you would on
a house but on a car it's hard to get
that but how much that car is devaluing
oh it's going down like a rock that's
and so he's paying $1,400 a month on
something the difference with your house
is that's an asset for you guys the
truck is a liability and where that
deserve statement comes in it starts to
to lose its power when you start talking
about what you could be doing with the
1400 00 here's here's the thing um Ken
makes a very very good point so you said
you're bringing home $200,000 a year
right so what 16,000 almost $177,000 a
month yeah 14 where he's at I'm going to
tell you where he's going for I mean we
have almost $177,000 a month 1400 that's
nothing that's what he's thinking it's a
very small piece of that um by the way
your mortgages as well but what I'm
looking at is
because you have so much income there
should be zero reason for debt how easy
how easy would it be uh and let me point
this out too typically do you have any
other cars by the way or is it just um
yeah y we have one more what else do you
have uh we have a Ford Explorer and how
much is that worth um I believe around
40 but that's paid off okay so typically
we wouldn't want you to have any more
than half of your income yearly in
Vehicles because they go down in value
so you're right at that I personally
because of your income I'd be like look
we make money we can pay this off or we
can you know what I'm saying like
there's I think there's a way that you
guys can meet in the middle $1,400 a
month that is just a lot of money to be
giving away in payments when you could
be debt free what other debt do you
have um a house and then I have a
student loan how much is a student loan
um
20,000 yeah so $100,000 in debt you guys
have you live on 200 you can pay all of
this off in a year and everybody's happy
yeah let's do it why not yeah awesome
that's what I would do because here's
the thing he does earn a lot of money
you guys do earn a lot of money and he's
probably like I don't need to drive a
galapia we earn $200,000 a year and you
know then paay it off but he's taking
out a loan on a
truck almost half of what they bring
home she said 80 to 90 she said
somewhere between 80 to 990,000 he paid
for that truck
yeah it's too it's expensive but it's
not more than half of their I understand
but it's still expensive it's it's out
of whack in that you got a loan for half
of what you take home he shouldn't have
got a loan he should have paid cash he's
got so much money he should they should
have been it would have felt so great to
walk on that lot buy it a couple of
years
used so spend 20,000 less and walk home
with a car in cash I tell you what
$90,000 for a truck that truck needs to
power your entire house I me you know I
mean it needs to do the laundry it needs
kid I mean yeah yeah put the kids to bed
you know the whole nine yards that's a
lot of it's just crazy when the value on
that is just dropping and dropping and
they're upside down I wouldn't do it I
wouldn't do it but I know I know people
do it I me we got people on Tik Tok
bragging about how they have joint uh
car payments of $22,100 they're like I
know they're crazy it's sort of fun it's
just like mind numb robots yeah no I
wouldn't do it but I would pay off I've
got that's what I got all
right we'll be right back this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show it's a competitive home buying
Market but there's a way you can get an
edge Churchill Mortgage works with you
to understand your budget and your goals
and the church hill mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Church Hill
has bumped up their seller guarantee to
$10,000 giving your offer the best
chance of being accepted and helping you
win in today's market go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Jade
warshaw and we are here for you this
hour Triple 8 825 5225 that's 8 825 5225
let's go to Kyle now who joins us in Los
Angeles Kyle how can we
help hi uh I was just calling I'm 27
years old newly married since last
October I just have like 48,000 of
student loans and the Federal loans are
just about to start being unfrozen
starting October I just wondering like
what would be the best way to basically
start with payments and stuff um I
wasn't sure if it would be something can
ask my wife who who can also help
chipping even though it's just my
student loan or is it something that I
should pay on my own well tell us first
what the actual uh minimum requirement
is going to be when it picks back up
what is that number it's only like 300 a
month and what other debt do you
have um just the I have one private so
it's splended two my private started out
being 42 it's down to 16 um I've been
paying that one since it wasn't ever
Frozen and then my private one's like
325 or my federal I mean is
325 I I'm sorry I thought you sorry
you've got 16k in the private you've got
I thought I heard you say so 48 total
yeah total okay I see I see um and
what's the payment on the private loan
um private I've been paying um like a
grand but the minimum is 811 right now
yeah um so smallest to largest in your
debt snowball you're paying the private
loan first to get that one paid off the
16,000 here's what do you have the
margin in your budget to pay the 300 and
if so what would that
leave um yeah so my wife just recently
like finished school as well and already
paid off her loans but um okay hold on
wait hold on let's stop let's combine it
let's talk about these numbers combined
okay so how much debt does your wife
have
none she just finished okay just
checking and nothing else right nothing
else no credit card debt no car loans or
anything okay so combined income if once
you start paying this $300 a month do
you have the money there do we need to
find it no I I have the money I just
saying what would be like should I just
finish off paying the private and then
work on the federals or
well minimum what I would do in your
situation is I would do the debt
snowball and I would do whatever you
know whatever you can throw to the
smallest debt which is the $16,000 debt
I would knock that out as quickly as
possible um in my situation I had a lot
of student loans I had more than you did
and I paid um I got lowered payments on
the other on so we'd have all the cash
we could to throw on the smallest
student loan pay it off and then keep
doing it like that so if you can cover
the $300 payment I wouldn't do that but
if you're having problem covering it
then that could be a strategy to free up
a little bit more money to pay at the
$166,000 debt Kyle are you guys joint
bank accounts or you guys doing things
separate so we have we have our separate
and then we have our joint um the first
year mayor she was still in school and I
just finished school and was working as
a nurse so I was paying for all the rent
and utilities I I I heard that and I'm
going to I want my colleague back in on
this but but I I felt that and heard
that like oh we have two separate two
separate bank accounts we aren't
we and and I I think you guys need to
understand our position on that you guys
need to be doing this together there's a
reason for that Jade and I think that
this changes the questions that he
should be asking and I think it changes
the math I because we've been operating
based on well this is what Kyle can put
towards it is they're not doing this
together yeah I you guys need to combine
your income that's I mean I I I can't
say it enough couples who combine their
income they build wealth faster they're
more likely to buy a home together
they're more likely to stay stay
together across the Long Haul like
there's so M so many statistics that
backup combining your money so I could
go on and on about that but practically
right here in the here and now you guys
will pay off this debt so much faster
yeah you know what I'm saying so have
that conversation tonight do you think
think that she'd be on board I mean it
can't by the way for anybody listening
when we say combine your money some
folks try to do the workaround kind of
like what Kyle and them is done where
it's like well we do have a we do have
an account that we put we pull some of
our money that's so sweet but that's
that's not the real deal that's halfway
yeah that's not that's not the real deal
Holyfield so how much money could you
put towards if if we do the dead
snowball so what I'm hearing is the
lowest the smallest debt you have in the
Deb snowball is a $166,000 private loan
M and your minimum is 8800 you have
personally been putting a th000 on it if
I'm recalling everything right how much
could you too put on that
$16,000 how much if you do your budget
you go we're going to take care of
everything else and then we're attacking
this debt snowball how much could you
put on it
together together um
4,400 off in four months let's go yeah
let's go I got one more question I got a
hunch J what do you have what do you
both have in savings do you have
separate savings accounts and if you do
what do you got I know I'm digging we we
have our separate and together and we
each have like so I just dropped my
savings into like the 1,000 emergency
fund and put a $3,000 payment good how
much does she have she has
$1450 and then together we have another
like 14 14 is in
$1,450 yeah okay oh okay I thought you
said so we okay there I didn't find too
much there I'm not much of a detective
on that one but we're combining the
money from now on
$4,400 yes you're going to knock this
thing out and we didn't even talk about
side hustles that's right we didn't even
talk about that I've been working a lot
of bonuses which the incentives are
really nice as a nurse good extra hours
yes good for you K yeah I get paid like
an extra thousand just for picking up a
shift and time and a half on top
Kyle you're paying off the
16 in less than four months M and then
the 48 that's about 10 that's less than
10 months M yeah your life
changes yeah flipping the script do you
hear the smile I just heard it oh yeah
see because you felt the hope you saw it
seemed like there wasn't a way out and
then Ken so masterfully crafted there's
a way out and you see it now and I want
you to go home and I want you to share
that with your wife because I want her
on board with this I want her helping I
want her going okay what can I do Kyle
do you want me to pick up some extra
work what can like I want you guys on
the same page and I don't want you to
think about it as this big sacrifice
okay it is a sacrifice but I want you to
think about it as a trade all right
you're you're trading a bad card for a
really good card you know what I'm
saying and when you frame it up like
that it it's far more motivating than
like oh man I'm going to have to go to
work again and oh man we can't you know
go out to dinner and all these things no
man I'm trading this bad uh BJ Armstrong
looking you know worst worst player on
the team for a Michael Jordan wow I like
the Chicago Bulls reference I'm so
amazed no bill cartright you know what
I'm saying that's better BJ was a good
shooter no John Paxton got give me the
Michael Jordan C Winnington big old tall
dude that can barely do anything BJ I
mean I got to give loved BJ Armstrong
but you know what we're saying Kyle this
this is what we're talking about you
you're getting the winning card it's
worth the trade it's worth the effort
and these loans are going to be gone
gone and then the emergency fund isn't
far behind Okay all of a sudden we are
rolling into baby step 3B saving for
that house I'm just really curious we
only got about 30 40 seconds with you
what's your combined income right now
combined since she just finished school
um I think together like 110 to 120,000
great and you're just getting started
just getting started Kyle you guys you
got this yes and I need everybody to see
cuz there's a lot of ky's out there it
was that simple it was as easy as us
looking at the budget looking at the
income finding ways that we can earn
more and K changing our mindset framing
up this this whole situation to go you
know what this benefits me this is in my
best favor he's going to look back and
then you know a year and a half his
loans are going to be gone and everybody
else is going to still be whining and
their income is only going to go up they
are going to be baby steps millionaires
the process works Kyle thanks for the
call really excited for you get after it
got to have a conversation with the
misses we got to get those bank accounts
together and then we're talking about
exponential productivity this is the
Ramy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level Nets weite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netw Suite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the ramsy show where we
help you win with your money your work
and your relationships and you know one
of the things that is so fun about this
this gig is we get to hear Amazing
Stories whether it be the debt free
screams uh here on the debt free stage
in our lobby of Ramsey Solutions World
Headquarters or the comments of social
media Pro uh profiles certainly our baby
steps Facebook group and uh so I I
thought it would be fun Jade by the way
Jade warshaw Ken Coleman with you I'm
sorry I did not tell you who's talking
actually you right now uh we are Ramy
personalities and we're here together
for youp 8825 5225 before we get back to
the phones um these there's some really
fun comments uh from our baby steps
Facebook group great group of people
and these are the I had it moments right
and they're sharing moments where they
got to the point where they went okay
that's it what I've been doing isn't
working I'm not doing it anymore Dave
kind of made this I had it like you get
sick and tired of
being sick and tired and so we got a
couple here um this one jumped out to me
this is from Robin I would have panic
attacks in line at the grocery
store because I was terrified my car was
going to decline it was a miserable
existence I'm feeling that right here in
my
chest um oh I love this Haley Joe yeah
oh this one hit me having to ask for
your parents ask having to ask your
parents for money as an adult was my
all-time low did it once never again
after that been there yeah yeah I I I
remember early on in our marriage Stacy
and I um brought not credit card debt
but we did have student loan debt and we
were paying there wasn't any more toring
back then and we were both starting out
we weren't making much money right and I
think we were probably five or six
months into marriage we had an apartment
in Richmond Virginia and and we weren't
on a budget we were just two young kids
yeah man and I remember taking her out
to eat and you know I mean we're six
months in tell me what happened Ken well
you know what happened you went to pay
for the Stak and they they brought the
card back yeah I'm sorry sir but is
there another card you would like us we
were so cluel
mhm sty was like well it maybe something
wrong with this card so she does the old
here try my card the way your bank
account was set up though go walking off
you know what I mean and you're kind of
in that moment going uh is that is this
a card problem or like we just so you
didn't even know like you didn't know
hey I know I don't have I'm owning it we
didn't know we thought we were okay we
weren't budgeting and we were just
living life man I know and we didn't
have much margin mhm and sure enough
were you so
embarrassed humiliated is the word oh
mortified not so much of what the waiter
thought of us but that we didn't know
and so I remember calling the bank and
getting the lady on the phone M cuz we
didn't have it like we got to pay the
bill oh that's right you can't you're
washing dishes otherwise well let me
tell you something we
luckily came up with some cash I had
some cash in the car that I you know
like we were like find the ch
like oh I'm not even kidding and I Prof
I I apologize we didn't have enough to
tip the
waiter Ken yeah that'll that'll get your
attention so I had to tell the waiter I
mean it was and the waiter was super
cool yeah and I said I am not going to
leave you hanging and I went back about
a week later and and and gave that dude
some money but like we we had to pull
from it was a it was so embarrassing
yeah it was right before paycheck man
and we weren't paying attention and
that's when I was like I don't ever want
to be humiliated like that again I know
that's right that is when you're looking
at the waiter going I got to come up
with the money to pay my bill or I may
be in the back okay that rolling up the
old sleeves washing the dishes yeah here
give me the macaroni plate I'll get that
that's a true story that's a good St
that was a wake up call I was like now
this was all pre- Dave Ramsey we didn't
even know who he was so we didn't
discover him until you know two or three
years later yeah but but that was a
wakeup call for us that we need to be
budgeting and paying attention to what's
going on so that's a good one wait what
about what about I'll be honest with you
I got a little I got a little I got a
little uh little anxiety right telling
that story well look at this one this
one says I this kind of reminded me you
she said I saw my husband cry at a
checkout because our card got declined
and we had to put things back oh yeah I
wish I could have put my food back but I
had already eaten it no I I didn't cry
because I was my face was boiling
M do you know that kind of embarrassment
where like you want to crawl under the
table Yeah well look at this I I want to
read this last one cuz I I I have some
thoughts on this she said when I finally
wrote my debt down on paper one day out
of the blue the number absolutely
terrified me I didn't realize I was that
far in debt I didn't want to get stuck
in that situation that reminds me Sam
and I were just talking the other day he
was like Jade the day that I realized
how much debt we had we were at staying
at his mom's house in the upstairs bed
you know when you're like in your old
bedroom that's when you gone all the way
down to the bottom all right you in your
your old bedroom yeah and you're your
new wife hey hi this is my bedroom girl
well it was his sister's bedroom that
was even worse so it's like flowers and
stuff so we sit we're sitting in there
and he pulls up you know what do you do
you go to Credit Karma to see and it was
like that was the first time we'd ever
looked at a credit report to see all
listed you want to talk about
hyperventilation
freaked you out man what the numbers
just kept adding up they just kept
coming just more and more zeros is that
is that the cuz I know your story The
Big total is that when you found out the
big total that was when yeah cuz I had
been kind of pushing him to tell like
how much is tell don't know your story
uh yeah so started out came out of
college newly married I knew we had a
lot of debt I didn't know how much and I
knew Sam had alluded to the fact that he
had a lot of student loan debt I didn't
you know when you're that young you
don't know what a lot quote a lot of
money is he was so handsome and talented
you didn't care oh thank God the man is
goodlooking he's a snack but let me tell
you when he told he kept saying Yeah I
think it's around 130 I think it's
around 150 I'm like well what is it so
I'm pushing on I'm pushing on it finally
he logs in looks at it $280,000 of just
student loan debt the rest of it to
total
$460,000 of debt between credit cards
cars everything El so that's a perfect
segue for our next caller I think I'm
just reading the board here let's see
what Keith has got to say in
Indianapolis Keith you're on the ramsy
show hey Ken hey J Havey Friday happy
Friday you too buddy what's
up yes so I am uh also recently married
um also within the last year got a new
job I moved down here to Indie um I've
done the math and it looks like over the
next four years uh given my spouse is in
dental school we'll be able to cash flow
about three and a half of that
um just wanted your guys' take on that
last half of the Year where we would be
depleting the cash um would we take out
the loan and then pay it off within you
know well immediately having a job or um
try to rework the budget now and with
this little bit of Runway try to make it
to where we break even by then or you
know dealing with a lot of you know five
years here a lot of time pretty much but
let me make sure I let me make sure I
understood you correctly so newly
married you both have new jobs she's
going to be a
dentist and my apologies my apologies
yes I I got a job so household income's
80k with my job she's starting dental
school right now so she's not working
okay and you have most of it saved up we
only got about a minute so only have to
pay we only have to pay half the school
year
right um yeah it would be it would I
mean so we're saving money before now
and then obviously um but real real
quickly you said that you've got three
and a half years paid is that
correct we will have three and a half
years paid three and a half years paid
how long is the
program four years okay how much would
you need to make
up um right now we're under seven by
17,000 doing the math don't take out a
loan for 177,000 what's going to prevent
you from getting that 17,000 between now
and three and a half years from
now um just having done the budget where
we're zero based uh hey you're going to
make more money between now and then
you're starting at 80k now it's 3 and 1
half years on down the road you got a
lot of road to make up that money yes
sell some stuff get a side job you've
come so far don't go into debt at this
point you've got to
$177,000 between now and then even with
a little bit of margin and a whole lot
of hustle you can come up with that you
do not not want to strap yourself with
that debt you're so close I applaud you
for having that much finish the job
finish well so excited for you Keith
thanks for the call don't move more
ramay show coming
[Music]
up
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds .c now and
save 40% off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more
[Music]
info
welcome back to the Ramsey show if
you've been with us Jade and I were
talking about some I've haded moments
for us and certainly from uh the stories
we get from you our awesome amazing
audience and if you'd like to share your
I've had it moments you can do that in
our various social media accounts uh the
Youtube comments Spotify comments we'd
love to hear your stories they're
they're
inspiring and we love to share them so
we're going to be doing that more and
more on the show so if you've got a
great I've had it moment uh share in all
those places and uh we'd love to share
your story all right the phone number
Isle
8825 5225 let's go to AJ who's joining
us now in Washington DC AJ how can we
help hi um thanks for taking my call
huge fans of you guys um I am calling
because my wife and I are currently on
baby step three we're about to move in
into step 3B
sl4 our household income is
140k the houses in our area are around
average
450k and I'm curious to know if it's
wise to buy a
condo um which would be cheaper or
should we just save up for a single
family house I'm asking because um we're
about to start trying for a baby soon
and
the plan is to have my wife stay home
while I work and I'm not too sure if we
can save up for down payment no less
than
20% um no less than no less than 20% for
down payment and the morgage be less
than 25% of our income or of my income I
guess so so the 140k is that that's the
combined income so if your wife if your
wife becomes a stay-at-home mom what
does that drop the income
to so at the moment it will be a uh well
at the moment
73k okay um but potentially could bump
up to 83 okay so what I would do is when
making the decision on what to spend
with the home I would use that budget
what the the money that you would be
taking in between 73,000 83,000 because
you've said that hey this is probably
what's going to take place and what
happens is if you buy your home based on
140,000 and she decides stay home you're
going to feel
strapped big time so 25% of the
take-home pay based off of the 773 to
$83,000 salary is what I would do and if
that I mean if this is your first
Venture into real estate I'm not mad
with you know a town home that's two or
three bedrooms because here's the thing
when it comes to real estate a you buy
when you can afford not when the market
says not when you know the economy says
when you can afford and you buy what you
can afford you don't just buy well this
you know in my area here's what they are
no there's always a spectrum of price
and it may not like you said it may not
be a single family home but a townhouse
may not be you know a bad choice for you
guys so I'd probably start looking there
it sounds like you're just by the
language that you used it sounds like
you're pretty acclimated with what we
teach here at Ramsey but we've got a
really great calculator
um to calculate how much home can you
afford and literally if you type that in
how much home can I afford you know
Ramsey Solutions at calculator will pop
right up and you can plug those numbers
in and see exactly uh what you need to
put aside oh and I can find that on the
website yeah absolutely matter of fact
if they can get it up on the screen in
time uh we'll put it there for you or if
maybe they'll put in the show notes for
you but we'll make sure that you have
that information because it's super
super helpful there it is right there
you can put it in figure out what's
going on and it'll help you out yeah
absolutely and have you have you guys uh
have you taken FPU have you done any of
that
yet we have I think we have we've kind
of like dragged it out I mean we we
listen to your show sure um but we we've
kind of like dragged out the lessons so
I think we have like two more lessons
all right good good good good I was
thinking of a baby gift so maybe Total
Money Makeover I feel like we need to
give we got even though the baby's not
there yet it's kind of a let's let's
exciting time exciting season getting
ready to start a family so hang on the
line we'll give you a copy of of Dave
Ramsey's Total Money Makeover this is a
great book just to as you're listening
watching the show you got a few lessons
left in FPU you know read a chapter a
day you know and just and then talk
about it turn it into a discussion uh
and and this is a great way to solidify
this process to really understand and
you know like you said you like you get
it but we don't want you getting it we
want you doing it because it's going to
really set you guys up long long term
let's go to Reading Pennsylvania now
Howard is on the line Howard how can we
help hey how you doing today good what's
going on Sir um so um number of years
ago my my we were pregnant with my
second child my wife was diagnosed with
type 1 diabetes and so we were concerned
that in the future our children if they
were to come down with something they
wouldn't be able to get life insurance
so we went ahead and got Whole Life
policies for them and I know you guys
take on whole life insurance I didn't
know how you felt about this situation
knowing that the potential in the future
that they could have something or have
you know to that extent that it wouldn't
be eligible for life insurance um would
you keep them would you get rid of them
what would you um well I wouldn't do
this here's here's why um when it comes
to Insurance the purpose of insurance is
to replace income that's the whole
purpose of it when it comes to life
insurance so for instance the policies
that that you have whether the one you
know you have uh or the one that your
wife has it's there so that if something
happened to you the people who depend on
your income would be okay so policies on
kids doesn't really meet that criteria
because they don't have an income and
there's nothing that you know is at risk
at that point and you would be better
off if you were really concerned about
them having medical problems you'd be
more you'd be better off just investing
money aside for them you know in a
brokerage account or something like that
if that was truly truly a concern which
I wouldn't necessarily recommend that
either I think a lot of this is kind of
based off of uh fear I'm not sure how
irrational the fear only you would know
that because you know their health
situation right well it was when they
were when they were first born so like
literally as they were born we put life
whole life insurance policies on them um
just to have insurance in place cuz I
know a lot of them are transferable
later in life so if you do come down
with something there you can still add
money to them without having medical
exams and stuff like that yeah but whole
life whole life it's life insurance not
medical insurance number one and number
two it's the worst possible life
insurance so I kind of feel like you're
you're using the wrong product to solve
a problem that may not even be a problem
it's kind of like you're just I feel
like
you're I feel like you have in your mind
what is a problem and what you're
telling me I'm like it doesn't sound
like it's a problem and then you're
using the wrong method to solve the
problem that doesn't even seem like it's
really a problem so you just cancel them
at this point or not I would cancel them
and if there's something that it's like
hey you don't want to say it on the air
that's medical going on with the medical
wise that you feel like you need to have
a pile of money let's just get with a
smart Vestor Pro and figure out the best
way that you're putting aside for their
future and I think that's a better way
because these Whole Life policies it is
the worst possible investment for your
money okay there's nothing worse out
there so I want you to know that um and
like I said if you do have a concern
about needing a chunk of money for their
health there's better ways to do that
with a smart Fester Pro yeah absolutely
get out of this product Howard there's
so much better things you can do and we
really recommend that you visit ramsy
solutions.com click on smartvestor Pro
find some of these folks in your area
have a conversation with them about it
in detail they can go in depth with you
and they'll help you do everything you
need to do but this this is I love your
focus though and I love what you're
trying to do and I think you're going to
find a much better much better strategy
um and that we teach and so again talk
to a Smart Vestor Pro in your area come
up with a plan and move forward from
there um you know it occurs to me that
um this this this month is almost over
it's hard to believe like I can't
believe it you know what I mean kids are
back at school in the Southeast
certainly and this is a big month for us
it's kind of like a secondary Christmas
at Ramsey Solutions and I want new
audience members uh
current audience members to know about
our cash giveaway so all month long
we've been giving away cash uh weekly we
have a $500 prize and then there's a
grand prize of $3,000 and you can enter
at ramseys solutions.com
giveaway go to Ramsey solutions.com
giveaway you can enter once a day and uh
no purchase necessary you do have to be
18 years old uh to win so go do that and
uh win some of Dave's money I mean come
on who doesn't like free cash I know I
do unfortunately you're ineligible I'm
not
eligible this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramseys
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
[Applause]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions broadcasting from the
PODS moving and storage Studio this is
is the ramsy show where we help you win
in your life with your money your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Jade warshaw
8825 5225 that's the toll-free number
for you to jump in we'd love to take
your call Jade's here to answer your
money questions I'll weigh in I'm here
to answer any questions related to your
work making more money uh experiencing
more meaning so you're not tempted to go
get a credit card to drown your Sorrows
on Friday after you've been just trying
to make it through to the weekend and
Jade will weigh in on those topics as
well
88255 225 let's go to St Louis Missouri
Kelly is joining us Kelly how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call sure
what's up um the reason I'm calling is
um just want to let you know like me and
my husband are in our 60s and we're on
baby step seven wow and I just want to
see what you would do um I work
part-time and he's getting ready to
retire at the end of the here and just
wanted to see what you would do in this
situation so uh a year and a half ago we
we helped our daughter purchase a well
didn't we didn't help her we purchased a
house and used our savings to to pay
cash for her a house because she was
going to divorce and was having trouble
finding affordable housing so um so so
that they would be in a a decent place a
decent housing so we bought a single
family home paid cash for it and then um
now her divorce is finished and she's
getting a some settlement from her some
property that they own together that
they're dividing and so she she's
interested in buying the house and she
wanted to know um about buying it and
what what we was going to want for it
and so um it went up in value though at
least
10% and so um and we've been renting it
to her at a discounted value like over
less than half of what we could get on
the fair market place but just to help
her out but um so she um so what's your
question Kelly my question
is should we I feel like we should um
we're wanting to give her a discount
rather than fair market value but um
she's um how much should you pay for the
house 234 and what's it worth now 275
275 um and we told her we'd sell it for
$259 to her only at a discount okay and
can she afford that and
does um she's going to go see she hasn't
went and seen but she thinks she can
because she has a chunk to pay down but
she is appalled and and um surprised
that we want to make money off of her
well we let me let me tell you what let
me tell you what I heard and I'm going
to give you a unbiased answer what I
heard from your own words is we bought a
daughter a house for our daughter yeah
but yeah now what it sounds like is we
didn't buy a house for our daughter we
bought a house that was a
rental and although we didn't charge her
what we could get for
rent it's not her house it's a house
that we can earn money on and I think
what I think based off of even what my
confusion was is if there was any
indication from her that that this was
for
her she even though she's not entitled
to it I think that's where the confusion
is cuz she's not entitled to it but if
the communication on this was anything
like this call there's a lot of gray
area for people to think well I thought
da d d da no it's this it's and that's
what happens sometimes when you do these
things for family they get gray area
really really quickly I would feel the
same way your daughter does if in fact
it was communicated clearly that you
guys were buying the house for her you
were going to go lock it up and then and
then she was going to buy it back from I
mean was the understanding that she
would buy it back from you no I never
thought she would be able to afford to
buy it I okay I thought we were G to
invest in the real estate market because
we had our money and just in the savings
account so I thought we was going to
invest in the real estate market and it
would grow while we're renting it to her
but I never thought she would be the
buyer because I didn't think she could
have okay so when you told her
well let me do this we're going to go
one little step at a time yeah did you
and your husband tell your daughter that
you were buying that house for her yes
or
no for her family to live in yes to rent
yes to rent so you so it was not her
house it was we are buying a house that
we're going to allow you to rent at a
discount that's what was communicated
yeah okay and now that's different that
is different so now the question becomes
um but I do I'm not going to lie I do
have questions about how well that was
communicated because it was not
communicated here on the the going back
Kelly was that super clear to
her yes it was super clear to me that uh
us that she going to pay that's that's
where her yes yes it was super clear to
her that she was going to rent that and
that's what we were buying the house for
for them to live in and they were going
to pay rent to okay and so now recently
the conversation is has shifted has
shifted and you guys and so she's upset
that because she thinks that you should
sell her the house for the exact amount
of money that you put into it yeah
because she's been paying us a
discounted rent she think she thinks
that's that that should have been enough
well she she's probably feeling like hey
I've put some money in I've helped
accumulate some of this Equity because
I've been paying the payment this is a
tough one it it's it's only a tough it's
only a tough one because it's family and
when you do deals with family folks
don't put things in writing the way they
should yeah what okay let me stipulate
the reason I think it's tough is cuz I
feel like I'm going to be mean when I
say
this but I don't think the daughter has
any right to be upset about the sales
price she's already been given a
discount by her mom and dad which is
very generous well it depends on how
again we're talking about cuz she could
call Kelly you're the one who called in
but your daughter could call in and say
this in a totally different way I
believe Kelly's telling the truth and in
that situation I don't think your
daughter has any right to be upset about
it I would just tell her I would say you
know what this is the price this is
messy and it's not worth the
relationship go out and buy your own
your own house that you love that you
can afford that's what I think that's
what I would like to see yeah because
Kelly and just to be clear I believe
none available there's none other was
available so this is she's well here's
the other question do you think as her
mama that she's going to be really upset
if you tell her that she's already upset
about the sales price is she going to be
really really upset when you go you know
what I think it's probably better that
you just go find your own house and and
and we not have tension over this is
that going to be a bigger issue well we
already had that conversation last week
and I said that's fine yeah she that's
fine uh go you can go buy something else
and that you can afford I want you to be
able to afford it and so but she go to
look and there is
nothing there's in her area that in her
price range that she can afford well
housing market is so tight well that's
she could buy something smaller then I
there's always something it's not an
Apples to Apples and she might have to
go slightly outside of her neighborhood
I guess where I was going was is if this
is going to be a big big issue and I'm
thinking about it if this was my girl
I'd go all right I'll sell you the house
for the number you want so that we're
all getting along I might I know I'm all
I know I'm all over the place but I'm
like it's not that much money it's not
that big of a difference to have to deal
with that it's just such an icky
situation it's a icky situation I'm not
going to lose my daughter
yeah they're baby step seven they can
eat the 20,000 that's what I'm saying
I'm not going to lose my daughter even
for 6 months over that amount of money
I'm going to walk away and be the adult
here literally and figuratively yeah I
think that's what I'm going with oh boy
Jade will tell me if I'm right or wrong
in the break this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by the incomparable
the fabulous
Jade warshaw ladies and gentlemen 8825
5225 8825 5225 time for our question of
the day the question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services after fires or floods
their rainbow restoration Pros offer
homeowners trusted full service
restoration expertise like mold
remediation carpet cleaning odor removal
and more visit neighborly decom today to
find rainbow restoration services in
your area very cool all right today's
question comes from Ashley in Ohio she
says my husband's company gives a 3%
match on any dollar amount with no limit
however it is in a traditional 401K not
a Roth okay I know this rule is due to
the match uh I know the rule is to do
the match then Roth IRA I just don't
know what to do when there is not a
limit to his match do we just put 15% in
his 401k or do we limit it and somehow
put and put some in the Roth he's 31 I'm
28 um there is a
limit my husband's company gives a 3%
match on any dollar amount well there's
a limit because there's a limit to your
401k that's number one so we're
investing up until that limit that
you're getting 3% on does that make
sense and then we're moving on to the
Roth because this is a better situation
for you long term because you'll be able
to take the money out of that without
taxes after retirement
and then once you max out that um Roth
IRA if you wanted to come back and do
your traditional and fill it up to the
rest of the limit you could do that
hopefully I made that make sense yeah
did I cover that Ken okay I think she's
thinking that the 3% is like goes on
forever right but it doesn't cuz your
401k has a limit so I want to make sure
I answered that clearly well you're
looking at me I'm not going to want make
sure that I not something cuz but I
guess when I think about it it's
confusing for folks way be confusing
yeah yeah okay that's good yeah you
clarified it it's the 15% and here's how
we get to the 15% and then here's your
options that get you to the 15% and
that's what you laid out that's right so
um each each year there's a limit on
what you can put into that and I think
this year it was 22,500 or something
like that and then with your Roth IRA
there's a limit so it's 3% so there we
go that's all right good stuff all right
thank you for the question Triple Eight
825 5225 is the number let's go to
Victor who joins us now in Hartford
Connecticut Victor how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call sure
um my wife and I we got married about uh
eight years ago and we're really good at
saving but uh not very good at uh
investing I guess so currently we have
about 250,000 in uh
savings and um we thought we'd splurge
on a on a new car and we got a car loan
for about
59,000 and the loan is for five years
five years uh five at 5% um how long you
been listening to this
show uh um I've discovered you about uh
I guess two years ago but I don't listen
regularly all right Victor do you know
what our position is on on taking out
loans for anything much less a
car uh don't do it don't do it and my
friend you've got the 250 in the bank
but no but no cuz I'm shook to my core
that you have you're spending $660,000
on a car I just need to know your income
and maybe my shook shooked nature will
go away but tell me how much your income
is uh well it's it's grown substantially
in uh recent years but uh this year
we're on track to make about uh 175 no
okay 175 combined yeah
I all how much is what's your what's
your wife's car
worth um the the worth of the car is I
believe um what' you pay yeah what' you
pay for it 6 64 no just over 64 you guys
are tripping you're tripping slipping
and dipping you got a 60,000 two $60,000
cars no no no sorry I I misund your
question yeah no this is the the car
that we
got the um this is just the new purchase
and do you have any other debt I know
but I want to know know how many cars
they have and what they're worth total
all right so so answer Jade's question
cuz she says you're tripping slipping
and dipping I think that's how that went
that is correct uh what is what is the
other car that you have and we know it's
paid for um uh we have a roughly
$155,000 car okay okay so the
$60,000 the $60,000 car and the $155,000
car that's
$75,000 I know I know it's high I know
it's high but they got the cash so
before I even get to that part I'm like
why would you take out a loan for a car
and Jade's going to get you to this is
the kind of car you should be buying
based on the ratios but why in the world
before we get to that why would you take
out a loan when you have no other debt
and you got all kinds of cash in the
bank I want to understand your
philosophy I don't think it's a it's I
mean I don't know if it's a good
philosophy or not but um we um our our
bank where we uh keep our savings
approached us uh with an offer to invest
in a um brokerage account so I don't
know if a brokerage account with that
going to net us more uh Revenue to
offset the the percentage on the on the
car loan that was your that was your
reasoning yes okay yeah no um it makes
no sense to me at all zero sense what
he's thinking is he's like well it's 5%
on my car I know what he's
thinking he's looking at the percentage
of Interest instead of real dollars
which is a car payment of what what's
your car payment on this thing uh well
real dollars real cost of the loan is
going to be 8,000 over five years that's
not what I asked you so you're already
playing games yeah you're playing oh no
okay what is your car payment per month
it's going to be around
11,00 that is just mind-numbingly stupid
yeah it's so much money it's just so
much money and here's the thing you
don't have to play these games you know
you're making
175,000 you're both working you can pay
for things in cash this car I'm guessing
was brand brand spank and new right
correct you're already upside down yeah
how much could you have saved by just
getting a year used a two years used
right probably
$20,000 like
this it's not worth it for me I have a
feeling that you're going to do what you
want to do because this your game makes
sense to you and that's that's okay um I
would tell you to sell this car I I
think it's it's I think it's extravagant
for where you're at
um you could pay it off in two seconds
and keep it I'm not mad at you if you
did I think you have way too much money
in savings um you said it was savings
but then you said it was a brokerage
account so I want to make sure is it
invested money no no it's not invested
yet U that's that's why I'm calling to
ask to see if uh it's a good idea to go
into a brokerage account no for that
kind of money okay so I'm just going to
briefly and this is not just for you for
anyone listening here's how we teach
it's a series of steps and I think that
if you filter it through this it's going
to help you all right in your case do
you have any other debt besides these
cars I put him on hold I thought you
were running that's okay that's okay if
you have any other debt besides these
cars we would take any money that you
have saved less $1,000 and throw it at
your debt so in your case we'd pay off
every single penny of debt that's baby
step two and by the way he has no other
debt but this new car sweet yeah pay it
off and then you've got got plenty of
money we would keep 3 to 6 months of
expenses set aside you could keep it in
a high yield savings account but not
non-investment money that you can it's
liquid you can get to it easily that's
baby step three baby step four is we
would start investing 15% of your income
every month into either your 401k or a
Roth IRA okay that's next then you know
you could save for your kids college if
you wanted to and then you would use any
money left over that you just have cash
sitting around or that's in your income
you can throw that at your home mortgage
to pay it off early so you've got a lot
of money sitting around um some of it is
your 3 to 6month emergency fund to be
liquid some of it's going to go to pay
off this car and then whatever it's left
if you have a mortgage dude throw it at
your mortgage I don't think I'm going to
be able to convince you to do that
because our minds work in different ways
um but that's really the way to do it
that's the fastest safest most secure
way to build wealth and I'm not just
saying that as a talking head we've done
the studies
it's true millions of people have done
it this way so that's all I can tell you
and that's all I'm going to tell you
that's all you can do good stuff thank
you for the call hope you figure it out
we're here to walk it through with you
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
we're thrilled that you're with us I'm
Ken Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Jade warshaw the phone number for you to
jump in is 8825 5225 that's
8825 5225 let's go to Chicago where
Robert joins us Robert you're on the
ramsy
show hi Ken hi Robert hey what's going
on hey uh I'm in big financial trouble
where we owe over a million dollars all
in together including mortgage
and uh yeah let's break it down
about 462 is the mortgage uh
96,000 student loan uhal 42,000 car is
that Student Loan
Federal no no no it's with Ernest I've
been paying it back for a couple of
years at this point
okay how much was the
car and the car is 42 and the car the
car is going I already decided that okay
good we're going to get rid of it
probably was $10,000 to $112,000 on it
but it is what it is that's fine still
going down the rest is the rest is
installment and credit cards and uh our
income is wait hold on a second 42 4,000
462,000
in the mortgage 96,000 in private
student loans 42,000 is the car run run
the rest because there's still a good
deal left is it all credit cards what is
it uh installments installment loans and
credit cards like private loans so so
give me the numbers yes I do have um
$50,000 like a solar panel loan as well
solar panels uh what else what's in the
credit cards what's in the personal
loans personal loans everything together
is
approximately
225,000
yes who do you owe that to what what
persons oh your favorite Sofi Sofi and
light stream and upster and
so and then there's some some credit
cards in there too so so here is here is
here's the thing we I've been trying to
be smart and didn't quite work out I I'm
I was was in a position where I could
lend money to guys who need it and you
know make profit on it so I would throw
money on a card or get the installment
loan and they pay me back and been
making some profit on it so you're
taking out the debt for other folks
right now one guy sto paying and it's
it's really it's so much stress I'm I'm
done with it how much money do you
make uh I would make 20 to 30,000 a year
net after all the cost did you say you
make 20 to $30,000 a
year yes that that's after after all the
cost my friend from the from the from
the you know loaning money I want to
know for your job
income the income is uh about 10,000 a
month no what is your is that your
personal take-home in your salary your
job is
10,000 10,000 a month okay it's like
9800 oh my gosh you were in no position
to be taking out loans for other
people yeah um yeah I could spend a lot
of time telling you the Ridiculousness
of all I mean it's it's it's one thing
to take out debt for yourself it's
another thing to take out debt like some
kind of a loan shark and loan it to
other people you know that I think that
you feel the weight of that I think you
know I hope that you
know I I do oh I think that you do okay
um is it just you do you have a family
tell me more no it's the full family
it's my wife she's sitting right next to
me here kids uh we have three kids okay
um all right so here's we have a full
house are you both
working uh yes she's working her hours
are a little bit right so and does that
10K involve what she's bringing in
yes okay I need her to work 40 hours a
week not irregular I need her to pick up
something that is just as solid as what
you're doing and then after she does
that and this applies to you too you're
both getting side jobs you guys are
about to work your booties off you have
to there's no other way okay so you
already said that you're getting rid of
the car you're going to take a 10K loss
that's fine you're still getting out of
32,000 of debt that's great solar
panels how is this is there any way to
get out of it uh are you able to sell
them have you looked into anything they
they essentially replace my utility bill
that's what it is right but can you get
out of them can you sell
them H probably out of loss well we're
getting out of debt so I'm sure it would
be1 to $15,000 loss if not more yeah but
you're also you're not thinking about
the debt that's gone so getting that
down to $15,000 that you owee is better
than 50,000 right yeah just getting rid
of the car and the solar panels if you
can do it is g to give you some more
room to be able to start really going
after these other bigs so here is here
is really the question I'm calling with
oh uh it's I honestly we would need to
increase our income by about 5,000 a
month yep
to I mean just to be able to F those
payments yeah you're going to have get
your after after getting after getting
rid of the car and everything so what's
your question and we're honestly if I
will float them uh credit cards will
start soon start charging because the
balances are like on zero balance
promotion and so on yeah so I I'm
expecting to get a bigger payout next
year in August September for what pretty
much it's it's money that's help to me
no we're not waiting till August it's
great that you have money coming but we
can't wait or depend on that as the
solution because as you've seen before
sometimes folks don't pay so we've got
to start today what's your uh what are
you paying every month for your
home it's about $3200 that's includes
mortgage taxes Insurance okay
I 10K a month are you guys on a budget I
need to know how far how deeply you've
gotten into this we started to budget
where really caught our spending
significant
and we we have a budet ready for
September okay I need it down to here's
the thing there's no breathing room here
we got to go and we got to go like our
life depends on it because yours really
does wife is working we're starting that
process to get her fulltime tomorrow
okay you guys pick up side hustles I
don't care what it is any money right
now is going to be so helpful for you
I'm looking at ways to get rid of the
car instantly sell off these solar
panels if you can instantly I'm looking
for ways
to do anything I can I'm looking at your
mortgage to be honest with you and I
want to know what it when when did you
get this house did you get it recently
or have you had it for a while two years
ago two years ago what's it worth and
what's the interest on it probably it's
under
3% and what's it
worth 600 we could probably walk away
with how much Equity do you have in 650
and gets so 120,000 130,000 Equity how
much 120 or 30 120 12030 we put 20%
down my friend I would be scorched Earth
now I I I would if it were me I'd be
selling the house and we would be
getting a place that is the kids are
kids they'll be fine I'd put them all in
one room I would be going bananas on
this too take that 130 put it towards
this debt get you some breathing room
your life is going to be so much better
so much faster this house is just as big
a problem in my mind as everything else
it's too much of their income it it all
is I'd get out of it now that's that's
that's what I would do and I'd rent yeah
it you need every dime that you can get
and all I'm not going to make any bones
about it all of it's going to suck it
it's not going to be fun well his life
sucks already but I'm just saying like
you know this is going to be the one of
those Seasons where it's like wow you're
going to feel the gravity of the
decisions that you made but the good
news is you can course correct and you
can write this ship and you can make it
happen and you're going to make it
happen but it you're it's not going to
happen if you don't do the things that
Ken and I told you today starting today
don't leave anything out don't try to
skirt the process do it hang on the line
Robert I want to do a couple things
Austin for Robert so Robert hang on the
line number one I want to get you in
Ramsay's number one Flagship product
Financial Peace University we're going
to give you every dollar as well the
number one budgeting tool in the world
and I'm going to set you up with a one
session with one of our financial
coaches this is the Ramy show hang on
the
[Music]
line
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my good friend and
colleague Jade warshaw we're here for
youle
88255 225 is the phone number our
scripture and quote of the day are
Galatians 69 our scripture let us not
become weary and doing good for at the
proper time we will reap a harvest if we
do not give up and our quote from Mark
Twain do the right thing it will gratify
some people and astonish the rest I
think if you were live today he might
also say it'll piss off a whole lot of
people too there you go all right back
to the phones we go Richard joins us now
in Providence Road Island Richard how
can we help hey how's it going today
good how are you sir I'm great so I'm
great now that I get to talk to you guys
I just started listening to Dave Ramy
show a few weeks ago and um because of
it I've already started to make some
changes but good you know I'm I'm in a
lot of debt uh throughout my 20s I
pretty much mismanaged my finances
mismanaged my life put myself in a car
loan that I had no business being in I
got a lot of student loans and I have a
lot of credit card debt as well how
much so with my credit cards I
originally I owed 12,000 uhhuh but after
I entered into a Deb consolidation plan
but after watching a Dave Ramsey video I
decided to exit right out of that good
so since then I've been um consolidating
my own loans I've been trying to
negotiate with them to get them paid off
so out of my five credit cards that I
owe I paid off three of them already
very good so give us your total walk
Jade through your total debt give us the
numbers and and and assign it what do
you got okay so I have $7,000 in credit
card debt okay between my two cards I
have 15 grand left on my car and I have
33,000 in student loans good okay and
what's your
income I make 47,800 for my 9 to-5 job
and then on the weekends I make another
maybe 10 grand a year so I pull in about
$3,800 a month okay 3,800 a month what's
the car worth do you
know I Kelly Blue booked it about a week
ago and it's worth about 20 okay and
you're how old I'm 30 are you single yes
okay what's your rent situation or
mortgage do you have a home or are you
renting I live with my parents so I
don't pay anything okay but that's my
problem I'm dying to move out
here day how old are you he's 30 years
you're a grown man try get look yes and
let's make that happen um you have no
money saved I'm assum assuming I have no
money saved I don't have any retirement
either and that kills me as well I
really want get started on a retirement
and a savings but as I learned from Dave
Ramsey you know right we got do in a
savings gotb you got you dating anybody
or you just kind of batching it right
now um so I Was a Serial dater not too
long ago and that was costing me a whole
lot of money I knew that was coming and
I decided to cut that off completely
because that whining and dining that
credit card bill was going up yeah so
Jay's going to walk you through this
she's going to walk you through the baby
steps and walk you through financially
but I want to say this really quick
before I turn you over she's going to
help you but I'm I'm going to push you
you're single you are no longer ready to
mingle you need to be working 60 70 dare
I say a week or two of a month 80 hours
a week because you're actually closer
than you realize with what Jay's going
to walk you through but you've got to
increase your income man and you
increase your income in today's economy
right now where you can get gig work you
need to be that little side hustle
that's only making you about 10 grand a
year that's not enough you need to be
bringing in way more money so I'm going
tell you that what's your car
note my card note is about $432 mon all
right here's what I'm move number one
move number one is I want you to save
$1,000 that's baby step one as quickly
as you can most people get it in 30 days
or less okay so that's selling stuff
that's looking around your apartment
selling anything you can sell you know
whatever you can do to get that $1,000
fast I want you to get it in under 30
days so that's A1 okay right after that
I'm trading that car in I'm selling my
$155,000 car for 20,000 and I'm taking
the 5,000 and I'm buying a car in cash
all right so you're freeing up $432 a
month then after that I'm going to take
that next thing and I'm going to get as
much money as I can I'm going to pay off
these $7,000 of credit cards you said
it's two how much is the smallest one
it's three 3,000 okay 3,000 so with the
432 a month that you just saved off of
selling that car you know how quick you
knock out three grand fast mm cuz he's
got more margin too cuz he's working
like a mad man yeah I love that do you
see how this works you see where we're
going with this yeah I definitely do so
you're gonna my guess is uh let's see
once we get that 432 cleared up how much
extra could you feasibly have in your
budget if you worked like
crazy
um so like I said I get paid bi-weekly
and then weekly from the the the weekend
hustle uhuh so I would say without the
432 well I'm getting what do you have
extra right now what do you what do you
have extra right now like if you cut
down your budget you cut down what
you're spending how much could you find
extra after all your bills are
paid I have most of what I make actually
because I don't really go out much so I
would say I probably still have at least
three grand left over I don't have many
bills so you have 300 you'd have 3,000
left over plus the 432 that's
3,432 boo that credit card is knocked
out instantly almost you're going to
have your credit card debt done in two
months but you're also going to get more
work right and so now we're moving on to
the 33,000 in student loan debt you can
have that done in 10 months less eight
months yeah understood and and then I
can move out right yes then you can move
on I would tell you this I think you can
move out uh in the middle of everything
Jay just gave you but this is this is
after we knock out the uh the credit
card and the car you got to have enough
margin for rent but if you're willing to
get a roommate maybe that's a good
situation I wouldn't wait till the
33,000 student loan if you increase your
income so that's why I was getting after
you about I know you want to leave the
nest and that's the right move but you
have got to increase your income and you
can do that go out on your own live but
I mean you're just you're rice and beans
and Jay's really good at creating lots
of dishes with Rices and beans that's
true she is yeah get yourself a roommate
you know if you don't if if if you don't
want to spend another cuz I think you
can be done with this in in within the
year if you're like I can't take another
moment at my parents house I don't blame
you if I was you I'd be trying to get
out too just know it's going to elongate
this process a little bit more which is
okay I'm fine with elongating the
process as long as we know exactly what
the goal is and we're still going to get
there you know what I'm saying I don't
I'm not as Jade would say I'm not mad at
you on that if you stay with Mom and Dad
a little bit longer but I think you
could do both and I actually think you
getting out on your own may give you a
little bit more fire to get this stuff
done but you can knock this out quick
but bro are you okay having a $5,000 car
I don't care if you are or not but but I
want to know if you are okay I going to
the mechanic all the time I will say
that I like the security of having a new
car I want to pay it off and then have
the next car for the next 10 years you
know because only 60k on the dash but
yeah but do you know how much security
you're going to have when you have none
of this debt mhm and you're going to be
able you're not going to be in that 5K
car for long cuzz you're going to be
again you're going to be out of debt in
under a year and you're going to stack
up some more put it you know get rid of
the 5K car and then you're going to go
up to a $10,000 car then you're going to
go up to a $155,000 car you see what I'm
saying this is how that works um but oh
you know what on the $115,000 car I he
doesn't have to sell it he's not in an
emergency situation so if you're willing
to bust it if he yeah if you're willing
to bust it what do you think about that
Jade here's my thing if you if you
decide to move out you need to sell the
car I agree if you decide to stay at
home you still got a decent Siz shovel
that's what I that's the way I would
play it I like can I tell you both about
my living situation that I might have
set up really quick CU we got 60 seconds
okay so my parents own a second property
and it's a whole entire house and they
want me to move in and pay $1,400 a
month get a room property as r i don't
like 1400 with what you make but I like
700 if you get a roommate well they let
you have a roommate yeah they will
actually I want to get my brother in the
house so okay dude yeah let's go I like
it at 700 I don't like it at 14 agree
agree agree 700 is the move and sell the
car because your brother's there if your
car breaks down you can use his I like
where your heads at Jade I like that and
by the way you said something that's key
for people that are going man Jade was a
little hard on that no this motivates
you MH to get out of this so we can get
a $115,000 car cash you know and and so
that's the whole point of all this is we
want to get you free of the stuff that
shackles you down good stuff good hour
Jade as always always fun being with you
my friend I want to thank James Childs
and the crew are keeping us on the air
we want to thank you America this is
your show this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the ramsy show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsey Network wherever you listen
to
[Music]
podcasts